Kapernick began a wave of protests back
in 2016 when he took a knee during the
national anthem to protest racial
injustice he was later joined in the
protests by Reed Kaepernick and Reid are
not currently on NFL rosters and
Kaepernick has not played since the 2016
season he has filed a lawsuit against
the NFL accusing the league of colluding
against him this week an arbitrator
ruled that Kaepernick's case against the
league can continue the NFL was hoping
the suit would be dropped the issue of
players protesting during the anthem
continues to polarize the nation a new
poll out Friday shows just how deeply
divided the country is on this issue
joining us to discuss this is Andrew
Brandt a former vice president of the
Green Bay Packers he's now a columnist
at Sports Illustrated and is director of
the Mourad Center for sports law at
Villanova University Andrew good morning
morning Anthony did this did this ruling
surprised you first and and where does
the NFL go from here it didn't surprise
me now we've been 2 years into this when
he first kneeled or sad that kneeled and
it's been going on census do you know
it's been a hot button issue in the NFL
and all over the country he won a case
that says this goes forward yep so the
NFL said they've been through
depositions they've been through a lot
of discovery the NFL said they don't
really have anything they went to an
arbitrator he said yeah we do have
something so the good news for
Kaepernick is we now have it going
forward we're gonna have more
depositions more discoveries see what
the NFL did or didn't do the bad news I
think is collusion is an uphill climb it
is a tough legal standard he has to show
two or more teams being collusive and
saying don't sign this guy it's not
enough for a team to say we liked other
quarterbacks we looked at Kaepernick we
liked our guys we like this young guy
he's more in our system
that's not collusion so the legal
standard is a tough one
do I think this is punitive I do do I
think this meets the legal standard of
collusion I don't it's interesting
though into it there's a division you
may have seen in that poll that overall
people think it's not appropriate to
take a knee but among younger fans 18 to
34 year olds 56% say it's okay yeah and
I hear from a lot of younger people that
say hey
this is our freedom it's right to
protest and the problem for the players
who are doing this is its conflated with
the anthem in the military yeah and it's
really not supposed to be it's about
mass incarceration and inequalities
those kind of things and that's what
Kaepernick and Malcolm Jenkins are the
Eagles continue to say but maybe it's
not heard and of course the president
brings it up in a different way and that
sort of energizes a different kind of
polarization well the polls also gauge
general overall interest so more broadly
is there a concern that they're going to
be seeing a drop-off that the NFL is
going to continue to see this sort of
downward trend of people not necessarily
being that interested in football we're
gonna have to see that because I think
it is still King the media deals are
always going up the franchise dollars
are soaring the metrics are north on the
business side but you're talking about
kind of a cultural social shift where
footballs become a little heavy it is
still King I think you're turning off
some people the real challenge for the
NFL in all sports to me is how to
maintain and attract younger viewers
because all these sports are skewing
older yes how do they get them there
more options out there maybe it's going
to be fantasy sports maybe it's gambling
something to engage on a three-hour
product that only has like 11 minutes of
true action the younger generation needs
more and maybe we'll see a shorter
product maybe you'll see a more
action-packed product in the future all
right Andrew Brown thank you so much
Andrew Thank You Lane